coinbase earnings they blew the
expectations out of the water as we've
talked about over and over and over
again on this show wall street analysts
make these estimations or kind of outlay
their expectations they're always wrong
on average they're wrong double-digit
percentages so 10 or more percent
usually is how off they are in this
stuff i don't know why we continue to
look at the expectations i don't know
why wall street analysts continue to
guesstimate what they think is going to
happen because they're just wrong
literally i could have went and just
made a guess and i'd be just as wrong as
they were so revenue was expected at
1.78 billion it came in at 2.2 billion
more than 400 million dollars more
revenue than was what was expected just
in q2 the earnings per share expected
was 2.3 dollars earnings per share it
came in at 3.4
which means that literally they created
more than a dollar
more in earnings per share
which if you look at it it's almost 50
percent off
the expectations was the actual number
and so when you think about the this
business specifically i should say first
one pay me in bitcoin
just pay me a bitcoin that is that is
where the world is going is
cryptocurrencies bitcoin etc
two
i was fortunate enough to be an investor
via one of the funds in coinbase in the
private market
we hold majority of the shares still
today i personally my personal opinion
i'm still very very bullish on this
business here's why
q2 net profit 1.6 billion dollars
up nearly 4 thousand nine hundred
percent what does that even mean from a
year earlier
it means that their net profit was up
almost 50 x yeah in 12 means they made a
bag
secure the bag secure the bag
that is what coinbase was doing the
monthly transacting users was 8.8
million
which is up 44
from q1
a 44 increase in the monthly transacting
users from q1 on top of that 462 billion
in trading volume that 462 billion in
trading volume up 38
from q1 absolute monster
business now when you look at the key
operating metrics here we're going to
pull up you can see all the way back
from q2 2020 to q2 2021
we went from 1.5 uh i believe million
monthly transacting users to 8.8
absolute insane growth assets on the
platform went from 26 billion in q2 2020
to 180
billion
this year
net revenue 178 million
to 2 billion in q2 net income 32 million
last year
1.6 billion in q2 adjusted ebitda
61
million to 1.1 billion absolutely insane
financial performance now when you look
at their trading volume of this business
the retail market
in q2
did 104
billion dollars of trading volume the
institutional market did about double
that 317 billion dollars absolutely nuts
what's fascinating about this is the
institutional market if you go all the
way back to q2 2020 you can see that the
retail and institutional market was
actually much closer together but the
institutional market is pulling away
they've got bigger dollars they do more
trading they're starting to pull away in
terms of uh percentages the
institutional market makes about
two-thirds of all trading volume on
coinbase today they added 1 000
institutional institutions
in q2 alone they do elon musk spacex
tesla so that means that they added more
than 10 institutions per day
coinbase and q2 added more than 10
institutions per day as a customer
trading volume fascinating ethereum for
the first time ended up actually
surpassing
bitcoin in trading volume on coinbase in
q2 if you go back to q2 2020 you can see
that other crypto assets actually
outpaced ethereum but not bitcoin now
other crypto assets outpace both of them
and so it's 50 of all trading volume on
coinbase is outside of bitcoin and
ethereum absolutely nuts to kind of see
how this uh business is coming now when
we look lastly at where the revenue
comes from so that's trading volume when
we look at the revenue of this business
what you can see is that the retail
revenue was 1.8 billion dollars in q2
institutional was only 102 million
dollars now why is that if we go back
and we think for a second remember that
the institutional market had two-thirds
of the trading volume but they only have
about five percent
of revenue how could that be oh i know
how
the retail fees are incredibly high
that's how coinbase makes money the
retail fees on coinbase are astronomical
institutions do two-thirds of the
trading
but only make up approximately five
percent of the revenue the institutions
trade way more and bigger dollars but
they pay way less in fees and so
coinbase loves retail trading on their
platform if you then look at things
around subscription and services revenue
you can see that
custodial fee revenue 31 million
blockchain revenue not sure what falls
in that 39 million and then their earned
campaign revenue was 16.9 and so you can
start to see that this business is about
five percent all
transaction revenue outside of trading
and then they've got 1.9 billion
in
actual transaction revenue trading of
retail and institutional clients
what do you guys think in terms of
coinbase to me is one of those
businesses that is going to live or die
with the macro forces if bitcoin goes up
coinbase does well if crypto goes up
coinbase does well if they continue to
print money keep low interest rates qe
the whole nine yards coinbase does well
it almost feels like coinbase will be
successful regardless of if they execute
well or not just because the macro force
is going to drive their business forward
as long as it continues in the direction
it's going yeah when you were talking my
biggest like thought was
it seems that coinbase is so intertwined
with
you know the performance of bitcoin how
much is it like brian armstrong's
execution like how much does that matter
is it though i
i mean bitcoin what went down like 40 in
q2 alone and
coinbase made what 40 more money
well so this is a great point because
one of the things for an exchange is
that an exchange benefits from
volatility in either direction if it
goes up a lot or down a lot then of
course you're going to get a lot of
trading people are paying attention uh
the media is talking about it a lot you
and i are sitting there saying oh man
bitcoin went down bitcoin went up
bitcoin you know is being volatile we
talk about it makes you think more you
go and you trade do all this stuff so
volatility is fantastic for these
businesses uh regardless of up or down
the problem is that usually what happens
is when there's a drawdown it's swift
but then it goes sideways and so you get
a lull whereas when you go up
you actually get a more sustained amount
of volatility so if you look over let's
say the last 12 months right we
basically went sideways from i don't
know maybe june or so maybe i think we
were like 8 800 of bitcoin if i remember
correctly during the having and then uh
we got all the way to about like october
like eight ten thousand dollars right
not not huge volatility kind of went
sideways for most of the year then
starting in kind of november november
to end of december we went from like 10
000 to 30 000. and then from january
beginning of january until maybe march
or april we went from 30 to 60 000. so
really from november to like march or
april we went from 10 to 64 000 600
increase right 6x
but then we went from 64 down to 30
and that drop
actually only took
i don't know three four weeks so you
basically had you know call it six
months of upward appreciation and kind
of volatility and then you had three or
four weeks of downward uh uh kind of
price falling and so you just get a more
sustained volatility on the way up which
means that it's way more profitable uh
for a business now what they've done is
they've also added a ton of users so the
estimate was they were gonna come in at
like 62 or 63 million verified users
they actually have 68 million so if you
think about it you know united states
only 330 million americans they've got
users all around the world but have 68
million people when an asset is this
volatile they're gonna make money as
long as they keep the service running
also coinbase was founded in 2012.
that's before robinhood gemini binance
it's like you forget that i mean this
company is nine years old at this point
yeah
it is nine years old but it's still
young right right yeah right like
they've got i think double the user base
almost of like a merrill lynch or a
charles schwab like i i think charles
schwab only has 25 or 30 million uh
users
nine years old and it's a 60 billion
dollar business
yeah so it's like robin hood which i
don't know where robin hood's trading
right now uh they're huge so far so
far.com pomp 15 billion dollar business
right like fintech in general has
drastically uh felt the tailwinds of uh
kind of this gamification uh
cryptocurrency uh young people getting
interested in this and coming up as a
digital native but i think that the
coinbase business the three things to me
moving forward that is going to be
important one the macro tailwind will
the interest rates stay low will there
still be continued qe et cetera if that
happens more and more people are going
to go to crypto
if
that happens
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies will
continue to go up in price great for
coinbase's business so that's one is the
macro factors
two is
can they compete with the decentralized
services so for example uh let's use
probably the most popular decentralized
exchange is uniswap coinbase vs uniswap
at one point earlier this year i don't
know where the numbers are right now but
earlier this year i looked and uniswap
was doing i think it was like a fourth
of all coinbase uh trading volume so
let's just call it somewhere in there
where it's material but it's not you
know kind of uh equal
and so when you think about that
coinbase is going to continue to come
under attack or competition from these
decentralized services i don't
personally see a wall street institution
coming into the market and saying oh i'm
not going to go use the centralized
service i'm going to go right to the
decentralized services but what we just
saw is 90 plus percent of coinbase's
revenue comes from retail investors not
actually the institutions maybe that
changes in the future but right now
those high fees is where all of the
revenue is coming from and so they've
got competition uh in terms of
decentralized services and then the
third thing is can they get out of being
solely dependent on the trading fees can
they get into other things right and
this was john you've not talked about a
bunch of times this was my whole thesis
on block five right when i first
invested in block fine over the years as
i've continued to invest more and more
is
block fi is kind of like a square in my
opinion right if you think of coin base
is equivalent to a robin hood right in
terms of it's a brokerage business they
want you to buy and sell volatility is
good for business volatility's good for
business the whole thing
but if you think about let's take
bitcoiners the ethos behind bitcoin or
the thought process is i go i buy a
hundred dollars worth of bitcoin and i
hold it 60 something percent of bitcoins
never moved in the last year right so
it's you made money on me on that one
transaction but then i hold it if you
look at something like block fi and
square it's a payments and deposit
business so block fi has a whole suite
of products that continue to offer
financial services right so you've got
things like loans against your crypto
collateral they have an exchange a
brokerage uh product they have the
interest bearing accounts they have the
credit card where you can get bitcoin
rewards back et cetera so what you do is
you end up actually building a whole
suite of products and so on a coin base
most of the revenue is generated and
concentrated on trading revenue if you
look at a block fight and it's got a
suite now all of a sudden you get a much
more diversified revenue stream you get
a higher revenue per user and you get a
much more sticky revenue over time
because regardless of what somebody's
doing even if they're not buying and
selling cryptocurrency you're still
driving value and capturing revenue
because they're swiping their credit
card or they're taking out a loan or
they're earning interest that those
types of things and then the last piece
of this is you take coinbase brokerage
business block fi is more like a square
and then you back it out into something
like a sofi sofi says we're not just
going to be traditional financial
services we're not just going to have a
deposit account we're not just going to
be able to buy stocks we're not just
going to be able to buy cryptocurrencies
we're also going to offer budgeting and
saving tools we're going to offer
refinancing of your student loans we're
going to offer refinancing your car
loans right they kind of go much more
holistically across the entire financial
kind of spectrum and so my thought
process is over time everyone just
continues to move more and more and more
to that sticky kind of product suite and
it's just a matter of how quickly can we
get there what's the engineering time it
takes but it's very obvious that the
businesses that get there they end up
having a much better business than
simply being a brokerage business and i
think that's what coinbase's big
challenge is going to be or maybe just
like the big opportunity however you
want to look at it is macro environment
has to continue to be uh attractive for
them they have to be able to fend off
this decentralized competitors and the
third thing is they're going to have to
expand into all these other services
outside of just trading if they do those
three things
let's go baby hey guys thanks so much
for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it